[موسيقى]
نبدا حلقتنا اليوم بحديث الساعه نتحدث
طبعا عن حفل توزيع جوائز اوسكار في نسختها
الخامسه والتسعين فمزيد من السينما ومزيد
من التنوع حيث تمكن صناع فيلم
سبع جوائز اوسكار على راسها جائزه افضل
فيلم بالفعل خطفت الممثله ميشيلوا جاهزه
اوسكار افضل ممثله في الفيلم هي اول
اسيويه تحصد هذه الاوسكار في فئه افضل
ممثله وحصد دانيال جائزه اوسكار كافضل
اخراج الفيلم ذاته الى الجواز الاخرى حيث
فاز الفيلم الالماني كل شيء هادئ على
الجبهه الغربيه بجائزه اوسكار كافضل في
الدوله وهو امر نادى نسبيا بالنسبه لفناطق
بلغه اجنبيه وفي مفاجاه غير متوقعه فاز
ممثل كندي برندريزر بجائزه افضل ممثل عن
دوري في فيلم الحوت وكان فريزر قد عانى من
زياده كبيره في وزنه وابتعد عن البطوله
وعن الاضواء ودموعه على خشبه المسرح ما هي
الا حكايه للعوده للحياه
اعتقد بصوره عامه الاوسكار كان رايح في
هذا العام طيب يعني انت
حضرت
الكواليس مثلا هون احاديث جانبيه ماذا
يفعل المشاهير هناك اول شيء من يدخلون
السجاده الحمراء يروحون على المسرح
عفوا يروحون على المسرح دولبيسيه على فكره
هاي اول مره يسووها من 1960 وهذا الشيء
لتغيير كبير فيروحون على المسرح الدولبي
جدا رسمي بيسي يسمعون مو مثل جوردن غلوز
بحركه اكو عشاء ماكو هالشيء جدا رسمي بعد
ما يخلص الحفل يروحون على
الجفر اذا مثل ما شفنا بهذا التقرير مع
الشيف بعدين يروحون على حفلتين
تقريبا 200 الف دولار حتى الشخص يدخل
والحفله الثانيه هي اللي جون وطبعا
الحفلات مستمره في لوس انجلوس الى الصباح
[موسيقى]